ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
BARRICADE HAND BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BURKE CALDERON CORREO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY
DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LEAD LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH
STONE TEEN VALLADARES VIA VIA
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER.
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
A
FLASH.
MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER THE
DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YOU
SEE OUR CON YOU MONEY IF THERE.
IN THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
ONLY GOD. LET US ENTER THIS NEW
DAY I SURE. OF YOUR STEADFAST
LOVE. AND DEDICATED SERVICE TO
THE PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT STATE.
MAY WE STRIVE TO HELP OUR WORDS
RELATED TO OUR NEEDS. THAT ARE
THINKING BE SHARP. OUR LIVES
SEEKING THE GOAL OF INTEGRITY.
OUR ACTIONS DECISIVE AND
COURAGEOUS. MAY WE THINK DEEPLY
UPON MY NEW PROBLEMS. BUT EVER
HAVE OUR HORIZONS EXPANDED I
MEAN. THANK YOUR MOM IS HERE WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE. MEMBERS
PLACE RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR
HEART READY BEGIN. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AND
TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. YOU MAY BE
SEATED THANK YOU. MANY TO THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO PERCEIVE TWENTY
SECOND TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
ASSEMBLY MINUTE NINETY ON THE
UPPER RIVER POWER QUE HANNAH
SYSTEM SPEAK PRO TEMPORE
AVIATION RESIGNED. RASMUSSEN
DAVIES FACT. THAT THE READER OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
TO. WITH PRESENTATIONS AND-
THERE AREN'T. INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
BE DEEMED. AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. LIVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN.
THIS PRESS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHT TO ALLOW THE
SPEAKER TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE OATH
OF OFFICE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ELECTED BRIAN AND THAT TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF A ARTISTS TO
HAVE HER SPELLS IN DAUGHTER. C.
AT HER DESK WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH BE THE ORDER.
LIVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING FILE ITEM ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME LEGAL
SEVENTY FIVE. ALL BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS. THANK
YOU MEMBERS. WE WILL NOW BE
MOVED TO SWEARING IN OF OUR NEW
POLICY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKS
BROWN. MISTER SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES TODAY WE WELCOME
ANOTHER REMARKABLE FIGURE TO
THE GREEN CARPET. ISAAC BRYANT
WHO WAS ELECTED TO REPRESENT
THE FIFTY FOURTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT. YOU HAVE NOT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO READ UP ON HIS
JOURNEY TO GET HERE I URGE YOU
TO DO SO. ISSAC RYAN HAS WORKED
HIS WAY FROM A DISADVANTAGED
PASSED TO A SUCCESSFUL
PRESIDENT THAT IS NOT UNIQUE
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT. CALIFORNIA
MUST HELP THOSE WHO ARE
DISADVANTAGED IN THE PRESENT TO
REACH A SUCCESSFUL FUTURE.
ISAAC BRYAN WILL HELP US GET
THERE. THIS OCCASION ALSO
BRINGS US A DISTINGUISHED
FORMER MEMBER OF THIS HOUSE AND
OF THE SENATE. THE HONORABLE
HOLLY J. MITCHELL SUPERVISOR
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
TWO IS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHANGE. WE ARE ALSO G. BY A
MEMBER OF LOS ANGELES CITY
COUNCIL THE HONORABLE MARC
CREASE HARASSED. ALSO THE REAR.
GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH AND
WELCOME MEMBERS AND GUESTS THIS
ELECTION WAS HOW TO FILL THE-
IN THE FIFTY. ST JUST. MISTER
ISAAC BRYAN IS THE ELECT
ELECTED. FOR THAT DISTRICT I
ASK ASSEMBLY MEMBER ELECT BRIAN
AND HIS GUESTS TO COME FORWARD
TO THE RESTROOM.
YOU CAN FACE
AND THEN. FOR PROTECTION. YEAH
WITH EVERYBODY BEING OKAY
THAT'S GOOD. THERE IS A CERTAIN
OF OTHER FOR THE SECRETARY OF
AT THE ASSEMBLY DESK CLERK WHO
READ THE SIR OF A- I SURELY AND
WEBER P. H. SECRETARY OF STATE
THE STATE OF. HERE VICE. THE
COR TO THE IN. CONCERNING SAKE
OF THE WAS. OF THE SPECIAL HELD
ON MAY EIGHTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE ON FILE IN MY OFFICE ISAAC
BRYAN WAS ELECTED TO THE OFFICE
OF STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DISTRICT FIFTY FOUR. IN WITNESS
WERE OF AYE HERE WANT TO SET MY
HAND IN A FIX THE GREAT SEAL OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AT
SACRAMENTO ON THIS DATE MAY
TWENTY SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. SURELY AND WEBER P. SAID
OF. WITHOUT OBJECTION MISTER
ALLOW IS. PRINTED THE JOURNAL.
I WANT ADMINISTER THE OATH OF
OFFICE. FOR THE OFFICE OF
MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY PLEASE
RAISE YOUR RIGHT HAND AND
REPEAT AFTER ME. I STATE YOUR
NAME. RON DO SOLEMNLY SWEAR
SOLEMNLY SWEAR THAT I WILL
SUPPORT AND DEFEND THAT I WILL
SUPPORT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE PROSECUTION
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC AGAINST ALL ENEMIES
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC THAT I
WILL BEAR TRUE FAITH AND
ALLEGIANCE THAT I WILL BEAR
TRUE FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE TO
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES. CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND PROPERTIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT I
TAKE THIS OBLIGATION FREELY BUT
I THINK THIS OBLIGATION FREELY
WITHOUT ANY MENTAL RESERVATION
OR PURPOSE OF EVASION OR
PURPOSE OF EVASION AND THAT I
WILL WELL AND FAITHFULLY AND
THEN I WILL ALLOW OKAY COOLEY
DISCHARGE THE DUTIES. GARDEN
UPON WHICH I AM ABOUT TO ENTER
ON WHICH I ABOUT AND
CONGRATULATIONS.
ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT WILL NOW
SIGN OATH OF A. OKAY. BOB HELLO.
THE. FIFTY I CAN'T. MEMBERS
PLEASE PRESENT OUR NEWEST
CALLING ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK
FOR THE PURPOSE OF INTRODUCTION.
UHHUH.
MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY I'D LIKE TO RE
INTRODUCE MY GUEST THIS IS
LAMAR PAR NOW MY PARTNER
SITTING NEXT TO ME. LA CITY
COUNCILMEMBER FROM THE EIGHTH
DISTRICT MARK WE SAYS DAWSON.
DR KELLY LYTLE HERNANDEZ
MACARTHUR GENIUS AWARD WINNER
FOR WHO I WHICH NOT I WOULD NOT
BE HERE WITHOUT HER. AND I
THINK WE KNOW MADAM SUPERVISOR
HOLLY J. MISSION. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO JOIN THIS BODY
TODAY THIS IS WHERE HISTORY IS
MADE THIS IS WHERE THE MATERIAL
CONDITIONS OF LIFE FOR FORTY
MILLION CALIFORNIANS CAN BE
CHANGED AND IMPROVED I'M
HONORED. THIS DAY.
THANK YOU
SEMI MEMBER BRIAN THE SINCE THE
SWEARING IN CEREMONY WILL NOW
MOVE TO REGULAR BUSINESS.
MEMBERS WILL MOVE BACK TO THE
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE WE
DISPENSE WITH THE SECOND
READING FILE. WE WILL MOVE TO
THE THIRD READING FILE.
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
THIRD READING. FILE FILE ITEM
ONE OH SIX EIGHTY TEN FORTY THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN FORTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THIS AMERICAN G. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS. THIS IS AB TEN TEN
FORTY- WHICH WILL REQUIRE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
COLLEGES TO OFFER AND FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATORS
STUDENTS TO TAKE AT LEAST ONE
THREE UNIT EPIC STUDIES COURSE
TO RECEIVE AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE.
I DON'T WANT TO REPLAY OUR
WHOLE DISCUSSION YESTERDAY BUT
ALL OF THE ARGUMENTS IN SUPPORT
OF THE HIGH SCHOOL AT THAT SAYS
REQUIREMENTS. APPLY TO THIS
BILL. NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT.
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS LEARN THE HISTORY OF
MULTI RACIAL MULTI CULTURAL
CALIFORNIA. I AM WORKING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATE WITH
CHANCELLOR AS WELL AS THE
ACADEMIC SENATE. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS EPIC STATUS
REQUIREMENT IS STABILISED. THIS
REQUIREMENT CAN FULFILL AN
IMPORTANT ROLE NOT ONLY IN
EDUCATING OUR COMMUNICATORS
STUDENTS. BUT ALSO IN FILLING.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
OF EXTENDED REQUIREMENTS WITH
MORE THAN ONE THIRD OF OUR CSU
STUDENTS BEING TOO MANY COLLEGE
TRANSFERS. AND THIS WILL ALSO
HELP REFILL WELL WE JUST PASSED
YESTERDAY IN TERMS OF THE HIGH
SCHOOL EPICS THERE'S
REQUIREMENT. THROUGH THE DUAL
ENROLLMENT OPTION. THIS BILL
SPONSORED BY THE LOS ANGELES CA
NICOLAS DISTRICT SUPPORTED BY
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MURATSUCHI MR MEDINA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. AS I SAID
YESTERDAY WE SAW THE- THE NEED.
AND THE AFFECT THE IMPACT OF
ETHNIC STUDIES LAST YEAR WE
PASSED IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
DR WEBER'S BILL MAKING ETHNIC
STUDIES REQUIREMENT IN THE CSU.
WE'RE GONNA GET AB ONE OH UNDER
THE GOVERNOR. AND MAKE IT A
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT. LET'S PASSED AB
TEN FORTY AND MAKE MAKE IT THE
SAME PER COMMUNITY COLLEGES
URGE YOU TO VOTE I AM AB TEN
FORTY. THANK YOU MR MEDINA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER
MURATSUCHI WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
BURKE WILL OPEN THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. HOME MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE A. OUR
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DO THEIR TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL YOU THAT I IS FORTY
FOUR KNOWS NINE THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GONNA PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM ONE OH
SEVEN MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
OH EIGHT AB TEN FIFTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BENNETT AN ACCOLADE IN
AMERICA MISTER BENNETT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU CHAIR I
RISE TODAY TO SPEAK ABOUT A
BILL THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
THE FOSTER CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA. AB TEN FIFTY ONE.
WILL CLARIFY RESPONSIBILITIES
FOR FOSTER CHILDREN MANY FOSTER
CHILDREN FIND THEMSELVES IN
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS. AND
OCCASIONALLY COUNTIES HAVE TO
SEND A FOSTER CHILD TO ANOTHER
COUNTY FOR SPECIALIZED CARE.
THERE HAS BEEN CONFUSION ABOUT
WHO SHOULD PAY FOR THAT CARE IN
THAT SITUATION AND THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THAT. AND AS A RESULT
OF THIS. FOSTER YOUTH ARE NOT
CAUGHT IN A RED TAPE DELAY WHEN
THEY NEED HELP AND ALLOWS THEM
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE QUICKLY
WHERE THEY NEED THE MOST
SERVICE SO I APPRECIATE. AND TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE FOR TEN FIFTY ONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER BENNETT
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF A.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
GALLAGHER I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE OH NINE AB TEN
FIFTY FIVE OR FORTY ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN FIFTY FIVE VICE AND
REMEMBER RAMOS AND OTHERS AN
OUTLET IN THE FOSTER YOUTH.
MISTER ROBERTS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU- THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER- AB TEN FIFTY
FIVE WILL BUILD ON AB NINETEEN
SIXTIES TO INSURE THAT USER
UNDER THE AUTHORITY OF A TRIBAL
COURT WILL NOT ONLY BE INCLUDED
IN THE DEFINITION OF A STUDENT
IN FOSTER CARE BUT THAT THEY
ARE ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR THE SAME
SUPPORT RESOURCES AS THEIR NON
TRIBAL COUNTERPARTS. IN THIS
BELT- TRAVEL STUDENTS ARE
COUNTED UNDER THE L. C. F. F.
BUT THEY ARE NOT AFFORDED THE
SUPPORT SERVICES AND RESOURCES
PROVIDED TO OTHER STUDENTS IN
FOSTER CARE BEING IN FOSTER
CARE IS HARD ENOUGH BUT BEING A
TRIBAL MEMBER IN FOSTER CARE IS
HARDER WHEN THOSE RESOURCES
DON'T REACH THEM THIS BILL
STARTS TO FIX THAT PROBLEM.
THIS BILL CONTINUES TO BUILD ON
AND EXPANDS ON AB NINETEEN
SIXTY TWO THERE WAS MOVE
FORWARD UNDER FOSTER CARE THIS
BILL NOW MEANS THAT NATIVE
AMERICAN FOSTER KIDS WHO ARE
NOT AFFORDED THE SUPPORT
SERVICES THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES WILL ALTERNATELY GET
THOSE RESOURCES TO THEM I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IN STANDING
UP FOR THE FOSTER KIDS AND
TRIBAL FOSTER. KIDS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
MISTER. WAS SEEING HEARING
FURTHER ON A THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED OUT OF IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AYE TO VOTE THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY EIGHT NEW ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES WE WILL PASS
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE
TEN THROUGH ONE TWELVE MOVING A
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN AB TEN
EIGHTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN EIGHTY SIX
VICE MEMBER AG WE ARE CURRY
INOCULATING THE ORGANIC WASTES
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MADAM SPEAKER AB TEN
EIGHTY SIX REQUIRES THE NATURAL
RESOURCE AGENCY TO COORDINATE
WITH CAL RECYCLE TO RECOMMENDED
A COORDINATED STRATEGY FOR
REDUCING EMISSIONS ASSOCIATED
WITH FORESTRY AGRICULTURE AND
FOR. URBAN ORGANIC WASTE.
REDUCING WILDFIRE LAND FILLING
HIM PILE BURNING OF ORGANIC
WASTE ACROSS SECTORS IS
CRITICAL TO MEETING OUR
EXISTING. CLIMATE AND AIR
QUALITY GOALS A STRATEGIC PLAN
ON ORGANIC WASTE MANAGEMENT
WILL PROVIDE A LONG TERM.
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AND DATA
INFORMED RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW
TO SUPPORT INCENTIVIZE THE
BENEFICIAL RE USE OF ORGANIC
WASTE AND REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS BOTH WHO DESERTED
THE- HOME MEMBERS VOTED VERY OF
A. OUR MEMBERS VOTED RECORD OF
IT. CLERK WILL LOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY ROAD I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE
ITEM ONE FOURTEEN MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTEEN AB ELEVEN
HUNDRED THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL LIVING HUNDRED BY
SUMMER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
ACTUALLY THE COMMUNICATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AGAIN GOOD MORNING THE SPEAKER.
AB ELEVEN HUNDRED REQUIRES THE
P. YOU SEE TO COLLECT
INFORMATION TO IDENTIFY NGUYEN
AND WHETHER ALL COMMUNITIES
HAVE THEIR BROADBAND AND PHONE
SERVICE RESTORED AFTER FIRE ORNATURAL DISASTER. THIS IS NOT
REAL TIME REPORTING BUT A LOOK
BACK TO ENSURE NO COMMUNITIES
ARE LEFT BEHIND. WHEN THERE
HAVE BEEN OUTAGES OF MY
DISTRICT I RECEIVE CALLS FROM
CONSTITUENTS THEY HAVE HAD
PROLONGED OUTAGES THAT I'VE
HELD HAVE NOT YET BEEN
ADDRESSED. AB ELEVEN HUNDRED
REQUIRES THE COMMISSION TO
INCLUDE IT IN ITS ANNUAL REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE INFORMATION
ABOUT OUTAGES AND THAT ALL
NECESSARY STEPS WERE TAKEN TO
RESTORE SERVICE FOR THE LONG
TERM. THIS BURKE THIS BILL IS
COSPONSORED BY TURN AND C. W.
A. DISTRICT NINE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. OKAY
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY KNOWS
FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTEEN AB ELEVEN
OH SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY GIRL LIVING- SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES AND
OTHERS ARE NOT RELATED TO
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. THIS
AROUND IF YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB ELEVEN OH SIX IS A BILL THAT
I'M JOINTLY OFFERING WITH
MAJORITY LEADER RAY AS
ESTABLISHES A PILOT PROGRAM TO
SUPPORT THE ENHANCEMENT OF A
REGIONAL TRAINING NETWORK WHICH
WILL WORK HAND IN HAND WITH
BUSINESS OWNERS SMALL BUSINESS.
A SERVICE PROVIDERS AND
WORKFORCE PARTNERS TO GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AT THIS AT
BILL LEVERAGES EXISTING
PROGRAMS AND EXPERTISE TO
RESPOND TO THE COVER NINETEEN
UNEMPLOYMENT CHALLENGES QUICKLY
AND GET PEOPLE BACK TO WORK THE
GOVERNOR HAS INCLUDED FORTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. IN HIS MAY
REVISED IS TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CONTRACT EDUCATION CENTERS TO
DO THIS VERY WORK I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. VERITIV A- ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED OF A.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES WILL
PASS AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTEEN THROUGH ONE
NINETEEN MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY AB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
A QUICK READ. ASSEMBLY GREW
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE OF STATE
GOVERNMENT. WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
WHICH WILL ESTABLISH THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATE OF
HATE. ACCORDING TO THE CENTER
FOR THE STUDY OF HATE AND
EXTREMISM IS TWENTY TWENTY
REPORT TO OUR NATION. HATE
CRIME TOTALS FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN HIT THEIR HIGHEST
LEVEL IN OVER A DECADE SEVEN
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN HATE CRIME INCIDENTS
WERE REPORTED. IN TWENTY TWENTY
AS WE ALL KNOW ANTI ASIAN HATE
CRIMES SURGED BY ONE HUNDRED
AND 49% AND HATE CRIMES AGAINST
GAY MEN JUMPED NEARLY 30% TO
SEVENTY CRIMES AND ANTI
TRANSGENDER HATE CRIMES ROSE
ABOUT 26% WELL WE HAVE SOME
DATA ON THE NUMBER AND TYPE OF
HATE CRIMES THAT ARE BEING
PERPETRATED EXPERTS SAY THAT
THE FBI DATA LIKELY UNDERCOUNTS
THE NUMBER OF HATE CRIMES
OCCURRING IN AMERICA. BOTH
BECAUSE MANY VICTIMS DO NOT
REPORT INCIDENTS AND LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
REPORT HATE CRIME DATA TO THE
FBI. THE FBI RELIES ON
VOLUNTEER REPORTING OF MORE
THAN FIFTEEN THOUSAND
PARTICIPATING LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
LAST YEAR 86% OF THEM DID NOT
REPORT A SINGLE HATE CRIME AND
WE KNOW. THAT THAT REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT UNDERCOUNTS
UNDERCOUNT. SO DUE TO THE
STAGGERING STATISTICS IN
CHALLENGES OF MONITORING
COLLECTING AND ANALYZING THIS
DATA IT'S CLEAR THE CALIFORNIA
NEEDS BETTER TOOLS AND
DEDICATED INDIVIDUALS TO HELP
US TRACK AND REPORT THIS
INFORMATION. AND TURN IT INTO
RECOMMENDATIONS. THE COMMISSION
ON THE STATE OF HATE WILL
MONITOR AND ASSESS CURRENT
TRENDS RELATIVE DAY CRIMES
PRODUCE ANNUAL REPORTS ON THESE
TRENDS AND MAKE POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR AND
RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES. AND
DEPARTMENTS IN ORDER TO HELP
THE STATE BE AWARE OF ADDRESS
AND HOPEFULLY REDUCE INSTANCES
OF THESE CRIMES. THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
HAS KNOWN NO VOTES AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU MISTER BROWN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE A.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY TO THEIR TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL ME THAT I SIXTEEN IS
HERE THE MEASURE PASSES WILL
HAVE TO RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS
ONE TWENTY ONE ONE TWENTY TWO
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
THREE AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME REAL
LIVE IN THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
AND OTHERS IMMACULATE IN THE
CANNABIS AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION- FOR THIS RUBIO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND THANK YOU FOR
A LONG ME TO PRESENT TODAY ON
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT AND ACT RELATING TO
ENFORCEMENT OF UNLICENSED
CANNABIS BUSINESSES. ESTIMATES
PUT THE VALUE OF THE ILLEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET AT AROUND EIGHT
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR ALL OF THIS ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY IS BOTH UNTAXED AND
UNREGULATED IN ADDITION TO
DWINDLING TAX REVENUES THE
UNDERGROUND MARKET PRESENTS
SERIOUS PUBLIC SAFETY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. THIS THE BILL HAS
ENJOYED THE SUPPORT OF LABOR
THE LEGITIMATE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT THE BILL HAS
ALSO RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU AND. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MAY RUBIO. C.
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED A
VERITABLE. HOME VOTED A
VERITABLE. HI MEMBERS VERY VERY
VOCAL BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. WE
WILL NOW TAKE UP FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY FOUR AB ELEVEN THIRTY
NINE FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS.
THIRTY THREE ASSEMBLY GO LIVE
IN THIRTY NINE WITH LIMITS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LORENA GONZALEZ
IT'S GOING DOLLARS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. TO BE CLEAR THESE ARE
JUST FOR PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
AND THESE AMENDMENTS ARE. WERE
NEGOTIATED WITH AN R. D. C. AND
SOME OTHER FOLKS THEY WILL GIVE
THE CPUC MORE TIME TO DOT
NUMBER THREE BY PUSHING BACK
THE TRIGGER FOR THE BILL FROM
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WILL
GIVE CERTAINTY TO RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS WHO OWN THEIR SOLAR
IN NON RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS BY
EXTENDING THE GRANDFATHERING
PERIOD FROM TEN TO TWENTY YEARS
AFTER THEY FIRST BEGAN SERVICE.
THEY MODIFIED THE COMPENSATION
SOLAR CUSTOMERS WOULD RECEIVE
FOR THEIR EXCESS ENERGY TO
INCLUDE AVOIDED COST AND STRIKE
OUT THE ADDED FIXED MONTHLY FEE
FOR SOLAR CUSTOMERS. THESE
CHANGES ONE SURE WE HONOR THE
INVESTMENTS ARE CONSTITUENTS OF
ALREADY MADE IN ROOFTOP SOLAR
BUT STILL ENSURE THAT GOING
FORWARD WE ARE NOT CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT A SYSTEM THAT SHIFTS
COSTS ONTO THOSE. WHO ARE
UNABLE TO MAKE THAT INVESTMENT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU MISS GONZALEZ WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS. ALL
IN FAVOR SAY AYE- OPPOSED SAY
NO. THE AYES HAVE IT THE
AMENDMENTS ARE DONE PRINT
AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS THANK
YOU MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM ONE OF SEVEN.
THERE IS GONNA MOVE BACK TO
TAKE A FILE ITEM ONE OF SEVEN
IS AB TEN FORTY ONE. BY MISS
WICKS COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN FORTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT THIS
pMISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
PERCENT EIGHTY TEN FORTY ONE
WHICH WILL EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF FAMILY MEMBER FOR
PURPOSES OF FAMILY CAREGIVING
AND SICK LEAVE TO ALLOW WORKERS
TO TAKE TIME OFF TO CARE FOR A
DESIGNATED PERSON. TODAY THE
MAJORITY OF HOUSEHOLDS DEPART
FROM THE NUCLEAR FAMILY MODEL
OF MARRIED COUPLE WITH THEIR
BIOLOGICAL CHILDREN AND SAID
THOSE FAMILIES INCLUDE LOVE
ONCE YOU AREN'T BIOLOGICALLY OR
LEGALLY RELATED DATA FROM THE
TWENTY TWENTY SENSES YOUR SHOWS
THAT EIGHTEEN POINT 4% OF
AMERICAN HOUSEHOLDS FOLLOW THE
TRADITIONAL FAMILY STRUCTURE.
CALIFORNIA FAMILY LEAVE LAWS
CONTINUE TO REFLECT THE
OUTDATED TRADITIONAL FAMILY
MODEL ONLY ALLOWING EMPLOYEES
TO TAKE TIME OFF TO CARE FOR
NARROWLY DEFINED FAMILY MEMBERS
THIS POLICY GAP
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS THE
L. G. B. T. Q. I COMMUNITY
CALIFORNIA HAS THE FOURTH
LARGEST LGBTQ I POPULATION THE
U. S. AND MANY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMUNITY DO NOT HAVE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR
BIOLOGICAL RELATIVES. THEREFORE
THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
BIOLOGICAL SUPPORT AND RELY ON
THEIR CHOSEN FAMILY INSTEAD. WE
ARE BEHIND AND MODERNIZING OUR
LANGUAGE AS A STATE ORGAN
CONNECTICUT NEW JERSEY COLORADO
EIGHT OTHER LOCALITIES
INCLUDING LOS ANGELES. HAVE
SIMILAR LAWS ON THE BOOKS IT'S
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO JOIN
THESE OTHER JURISDICTIONS AND
ENSURE THAT RESIDENTS HAVE THE
RIGHT. TO CARE FOR THEIR LOVED
ONES REGARDLESS OF THEIR BLOOD
OR LEGAL RELATIONSHIP. A. B.
TEN FORTY ONE IS SPONSORED BY
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES CALIFORNIA
LAWYERS EMPLOYMENT ASSOCIATION
AND LEGAL IT WORK. IT'S ALSO
SUPPORTED BY A NUMBER OF OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS ACLU
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S LAW CENTER
AND OTHERS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
WICKS MISS PARA QUE HAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. TODAY I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TEN FORTY ONE AND
AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR. AS THE
AUTHOR OF THIS LEGISLATION
SPOKE ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S FILLED
WITH DIVERSE MULTI GENERATIONAL
FAMILIES AND THIS BODY HAS MADE
EFFORTS TO ENSURE. THAT
GRANDPARENTS AND OTHER
BIOLOGICAL RELATIVES WHO CARE
FOR INDIVIDUALS CAN TAKE THAT
LEAVE. BUT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'M SURE MANY OF US KNOW
ON THIS FLOOR. IS IT ISN'T
ALWAYS THE BIOLOGICAL FAMILY
THAT IS THERE TO CARE FOR
CHILDREN WHEN THERE AND WHEN
THEY'RE ILL OR IN NEED.
PERSONALLY MY PARENTS LEFT
THEIR HOME STATE AND MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA TO BE A PART OF WHAT
SILICON VALLEY WAS GOING TO
BECOME. THEY HAD NO FAMILY
AROUND. SO WITH MY DIANNE AS I
CALLED HER WASN'T ACTUALLY MY
GRANDMOTHER WHO IS ALWAYS THE
GRANDMOTHER IN MY LIFE. AND
WHEN MY MOM WAS AVAILABLE IT
WAS MY DIANNE WHO TOOK CARE OF
ME. SHE I WOULD HAVE BEEN HER
DESIGNATED PERSON IN EACH OF US
KNOWS FAMILY LIKE THAT BE LGBTQ
INDIVIDUALS OR INDIVIDUALS FAR
FROM. THE HOMES WHERE THEY WERE
RAISED AND THEY DESERVE THE
SAME RIGHTS AS EVERYBODY ELSE
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT MEASURE. BUT
SHE DIDN'T TAKE LIGHTLY THE
IMPACTED THIS WOULD HAVE ON
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESSES AND SHE
WORKS CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
ENSURING THAT IT IS NARROW. AND
THAT YOU HAVE TO DESIGNATE THE
PERSON SO IT IS EASY FOR
BUSINESSES TO FOLLOW AND THEY
CAN COMPLY WITHOUT FEAR OF
UNNECESSARY LITIGATION. SO HE'S
BEEN REMOVED FROM THE JOCULAR
LESS THAN I'M A PROUD. COOPER
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
EITHER. THANK YOU MISTER. HIM
MR WARD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
FORTY ONE I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND OF COURSE OUR
SPONSOR EQUALITY CALIFORNIA FOR
BRINGING THIS. BILL FORWARD.%
YOU KNOW I LOVE THAT WE LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. I LOVE CALIFORNIA
VALUES THAT WE KNOW THAT WE
APPRECIATE PEOPLE FOR WHO THEY
ARE WE APPRECIATE AND WE
ACCEPT. THERE ARE THEMSELVES ON
AND THEIR EXPRESSIONS AND THEIR
FAMILY NETWORKS. AND I LOVE
THAT WE ARE VERY THOUGHTFUL AS
WELL ABOUT THINKING ABOUT
EMPLOYEE EMPLOYER BENEFITS.
THINGS LIKE PAID FAMILY LEAVE
SICK TIME AND OTHER- SO THAT WE
HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE CAN CARE FOR
THE FAMILY MEMBERS AND I LOVE.
THAT THIS BILL ACTUALLY
CONNECTS THE TWO BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE MODERNIZE.
THE STATUE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WERE REFLECTING PARTICULARLY
THOSE IN THE LGBT COMMUNITY BUT
OTHERS THAT DON'T HAVE
TRADITIONAL BIOLOGICAL
RELATIVES. BUT RATHER CHOSEN
FAMILY THAT I HAVE BEEN A PART
OF THEIR LIVES THE FOR ALL
INTENSIVE PURPOSES HAVE BEEN
EQUAL. IN THAT RELATIONSHIP
STRUCTURE THAT THOSE BENEFITS
ARE GOING TO BE A FOUR TO THAN
IN THEIR TIME OF NEED I THINK
THAT'S REALLY CONNECTS
CALIFORNIA VALUES I WANT TO
THANK AND COMMEND THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING THIS ON T'S
IMPORTANT. IT'S GOING TO HELP
SO MANY FAMILIES ACROSS THE
STATE AND SO I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A. B. TEN FORTY ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER WORK. SEEING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. OUR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM IS WHICH YOU
MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK ABOUT. LOCAL
OF THE ROLE MEMBERS OF. WHAT IS
THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. AND- WELL.
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP IS
FORTY SIX KNOWS FIFTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING BACK IN FILE ORDER TO
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY FIVE AB
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN
FORTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING. WE
SEEM TO NOT HAVE A RESTAURANT
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE. WE'RE
GONNA PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN. WE
WILL PASS THIRTEEN AND FILE
ITEMS ONE TWENTY SIX THROUGH
ONE TWENTY FIVE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY AB ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY GIRL LEVIN NINETY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AND
OTHERS AND I REALLY NEW
CONSERVATIVES SHIP. HELLO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MANAGE RECURRING
COLLEAGUES THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN NINETY FOUR WITH
RESPECT TO CONSERVATIVE SHIPS
AS WE KNOW. THIS WAS PUT BACK
ON OUR RADAR WITH RECENT.
INCIDENTS AND DOCUMENTARIES
WHICH HELP SHED LIGHT. ON
CONSTRICTOR SHIFTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND AFTER HEARING
ABOUT MORE OF THESE ISSUES WE
KNEW THAT SOMETHING JUST WASN'T
RIGHT HERE. SOME WOULD SAY THAT
THE CURRENT POLITICAL SYSTEM IS
A CIRCUS. AND A BROKEN SYSTEM
AND IN FACT THERE IS A MAJOR
EFFORT BACK IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
WHICH DID NOT TAKE. EFFECT DUE
TO THE TOXIC ECONOMIC RECESSION
THAT STARTED BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. OF COURSE
AND MAJOR OOPS. IT SHOULD BE
CRIMINAL TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
INDIVIDUALS BEING PLACED IN
CONSERVATORSHIP. AND SUBJECTED
TO ABUSE THIS GIVES US MORE
PROTECTIONS. AND IT IS OUR
PREROGATIVE AS LEGISLATORS TO
HELP PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF THE
FIDUCIARIES BUREAU AND PROVIDE
TOOLS FOR ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT.
WE ARE OF COURSE LUCKY TO BE IN
THIS POSITION TO ADVOCATE FOR
THIS CAUSE PLEASE HELP US MAKE
OUR CURRENT LAWS AND STRONGER
THAN YESTERDAY. BY VOTING I ON
THIS MEASURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MR LOS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THAT I SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
LIVING BACK TO PILOT A ONE
TWENTY FIVE AB ELEVEN FORTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
OF WHOM LIVE IN FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS AN ACRONYM
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING THREE
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS SO WE
ALL KNOW IN CALIFORNIA THAT THE
ONE AREA WHERE WE'VE GOTTEN A
GREAT JOB OF REDUCING OUR
EMISSIONS FOR GREENHOUSE GLASS
GAS REDUCTIONS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. WITH
TRANSPORTATION REFER
RESPONSIBLE FOR APPROXIMATELY
40% OF OUR GHG EMISSIONS. WE
ALSO KNOW WE COULD DO A BETTER
JOB PLANNING AROUND GETTING
PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR CARS
MEANING HAVING BETTER
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR WALKING AND
BIKING. MEANING CITIES PLANNING
FOR DEVELOPMENT THAT HELPS
CONNECTPEOPLE MORE CLOSELY
BETWEEN THEIR JOBS AND THEIR
HOMES AND DIFFERENT AMENITIES
AB FORTY SEVEN SIMPLY TRIES TO
BUILD ON THE PASS IS AVAILABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGIES ORIGINALLY
INTRODUCED IN THIS CHAMBER BY
DARRELL STEINBERG. IT DOES THIS
BY GIVING GOT MORE DIRECTION
FOR NGOS ABOUT HOW TO DO
PLANNING IT ALSO DOES THIS BY
GIVING A VERY LARGE GRANT OF
MONEY TO THOSE SAME NGOS FOR
TRANSFORMATIVE AFTER
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
PROJECTS THAT WILL CONNECT BY
PASS TOGETHER CONNECT
COMMUNITIES. BY BIKING AND
WALKING TO OTHER AMENITIES LIKE
JOB CENTERS THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND IT HAS A LOT OF
SUPPORT FROM GROUPS LIKE THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
KALYAN BE A NEXT GEN WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST AN IDOL
THANK YOU. THE YOU MISREAD
SEEING HEARING FURTHER TO ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE A- ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE A. BURKE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TALENTED I FIFTY
KNOWS FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES. LIVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY ONE AB TWELVE OH ONE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE ALL ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TíNH AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE OF SOLID WASTE
THIRTEEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWELVE A ONE REQUIRES PRODUCTS
TO BE HIGHER QUALITY STANDARDS
IN ORDER TO BE LABELED
COMPOSTABLE. THE BILL ALSO BANS
ANY PRODUCTS WITH INTENTIONALLY
ADDED P. FAST AND EXTREMELY
HARMFUL CHEMICAL OF GROSS FROM
THE HARMFUL CLASS OF FOREVER
CHEMICALS FROM BEING LABELED AS
COMPOSTABLE SINCE IT WOULD
CONTAMINATE THE COMPOST REMAIN
INDIFFERENT OUR FOOD CHAIN. A.
B. TWELVE A ONE HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
NATURAL RESOURCES. AND APPROACH
TO RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER TANKS AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS THERE TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. SO HOW MEMBERS VOTED
OUT OF. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. WELL PATH RETAINING
FILE ITEMS ONE THIRTY TWO AND
ONE THIRTY THREE WILL GO TO
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FOUR FOR
PURPOSES AMENDMENTS AB TWELVE
FIFTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTEEN
WITH THE MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH. IT'S A
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
PURPOSES AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER THESE ARE SOME
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS ADDING OUR
COLLEAGUE FRIEND OCEANSIDE IS A
JOINT AUTHORS. ASK YOUR ABOUT
THINKING. THANK YOU WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO
THE AYES HAVE AT THE MOMENT-
DARTED OUT TO PRINT IT BACK ON
FILE.
FILE ITEM OF ONE FORTY
TWO AB TWELVE NINETY FOUR THE
CLERK WILL READ. PHYLUM. ONE
FORTY TWO. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE AND
CHILDCARE IN THE CLEAR NEAR TO
CEDAR OF TAKE BACK. WORK YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ALAMEDA AND
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY OPERATED
PILOT PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
SUBSIDIES TO FAMILIES WHO DUE
TO THE HIGH COST OF LIVING IN
THESE COUNTIES ARE UNABLE TO
GET ACCESS TO LOW COST AND HIGH
QUALITY CHILD CARE. AB TWELVE
NINETY FOUR REMOVES THE SUNSET
FROM THE SUCCESSFUL CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS AND MAKE THESE
PROGRAMS PERMANENT TWELVE
NINETY FOUR IS SUPPORTED BY THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS COUNTY SANTA CLARA
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY CLUB
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DR BEING NO FURTHER TO ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. OF A- ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLAND GALLAGHER
I SIXTY FIVE NOTES HERE ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO ON
THE BILL I MEASURE PASSES. WILL
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS ONE
THIRTY FIVE OR. ONE FORTY ONE.
LIVING DOWN IN FILE ORDER
MEMBERS TO FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY
FIVE AB NINE FIFTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON IMMACULATE IN THE
PEACE PEACE OFFICERS. IF YOU
GET CAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE FIVE EIGHT WHICH
SEEKS TO BAN POLICE GANGS ALSO
KNOWN AS CLICKS IN EVERY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT BOTH IN THE PUBLIC THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE AND THE APPROPRIATION
AND WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT SUPPORT WHEN WE SPEAK
ABOUT POLICE REFORM. WE CAN'T
DO WE CAN DO THIS- WE HAVE TO
DO THIS FROM THE LENS OF A
COMPREHENSIVE LANCE. HOW CAN WE
EXPECT. OFFICERS TO A POLL
PUBLIC SAFETY AND TRUST. IF HE
OR SHE IS. IN THE COMMUNITY.
HAVE BEEN PRESSURED. TO BE PART
OF A POLICE OFFICER CLICK OR
GANG. IF THEY REFUSE TO JOIN
THEY ARE OSTRACIZED. THEY'RE
OSTRACIZED LACKS SUPPORT
INTIMIDATED AND LEFT
UNSUPPORTED REPORT FROM MY OLD
ON LAW SCHOOL ALLEGE THAT
NEARLY FIFTY YEARS OF ACTIVE
ACTIVE ACTIVITIES AMONG
EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT CLIQUES IN
LOS ANGELES ALONE SOME OF THEM
HAVE TAX USE. HAND SIGNALS
RITUALS THAT ARE SIMILAR TO THE
CRIMINAL STREET GANGS THAT
EXIST IN OUR STATE ALLOWING A
CULTURE OF POLICE CLICKS TO
CONTINUE IS AN IMPEDIMENT TO
BUILDING AND PRESERVING THE
TRUST BETWEEN CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THIS IS ALSO DANGEROUS THIS IS
ALSO DANGER IN THE REPUTATION
OF GOOD POLICE OFFICERS AS A
WHOLE MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE ON A. B. NINE
FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
GIBSON MISTER LACK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AB NINE FIFTY EIGHT. THE
BILL THAT WOULD HOLD LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR BEHAVIOR
BOTH WHILE IN AND OUT OF
UNIFORM. STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT A CAREER IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS ONE OF THE MOST
STRESSFUL DANGEROUS JOBS IN THE
NATION. BUT THIS IS NO EXCUSE
FOR A GROUP OF OFFICERS WERE
TAKEN ILLICIT. OR VERY
DANGEROUS BEHAVIOR. IT IS A
POLICE OFFICER'S DUTY TO STAND
IN LINE OF DANGER TO BE A
SOURCE OF SAFETY. AND A CRISIS.
OFFICERS A PARTICIPATING GAINES
REAL LEGAL CLINICS OF NO PLACE
IN FORCING THE LAWS OF THE
STATE. IF WE CANNOT GUARANTEE
THE POLICE OFFICERS ARE
FOLLOWING THE LAW HOW CAN WE
ALSO VERY IS TO ABIDE BY IT.
WHETHER IN UNIFORM OR NOT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS MUST BE
AN EXAMPLE FOR OTHERS PARTAKING
IN ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES CANNOT BE
PERMITTED. BY ACTIVELY ROOTING
OUT BAD ACTORS THE STATE WILL
ENSURE THAT ONLY QUALIFIED
EXCEPTIONAL OFFICERS. ARE
POLICING OUR COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR LACKEY SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER GETS IT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OUT OF HERE I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE. WHO SERVED
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR MANY
MANY YEARS FOR HIS COMMENTS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR STRONG AYE
VOTE ON NINE FIFTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. BURKE WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IN THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED THERE TO VOTE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TELL YOU
THAT I FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE
THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK UP IN FILE
ORDER TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE
AB SEVEN OH ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY RULE SEVEN A
WORN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORENA
GONZALEZ AN ACCOLADE TO
EMPLOYMENT. FIFTEEN DOLLARS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. I THINK THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER. I GOTTA BE
HONEST- WE SHOULDN'T NEED A
BILL LIKE AB SEVEN A ONE YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO TELL THE
BIGGEST CORPORATION IN THE
WORLD THAT THEY NEED TO ALLOW
THEIR WORKERS TO GO TO THE
BATHROOM OR WASH THEIR HANDS.
IT IS ATROCIOUS THAT WE HAVE TO
DO A BILL LIKE THIS BUT THE
HONESTY IS THAT WE HAVE A
CORPORATION WHO IS RUNNING
WAREHOUSES AND IT'S CREATED A
SYSTEM BY WHICH WORKERS ARE
GETTING INJURED AT TWICE THE
RATE OF OTHER WAREHOUSES THREE
TIMES THE RATE OF OTHER
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES SOMETHING
IS GOING WRONG. WHAT AB SEVEN
OH ONE WILL DO IS ENSURE THAT
LARGE WAREHOUSES WAREHOUSES
WITH OVER A HUNDRED PEOPLE
EMPLOYED AT THE WAREHOUSE OVER
A THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
TELLING THE WORKERS IF THEY
HAVE A QUOTA. WHAT THAT QUOTA
IS. AND IF THEY DON'T MEET THAT
QUOTA WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO THEM.
IT REQUIRES THAT ANY HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS SUCH AS GOING
TO THE BATHROOM OR WASH YOUR
HANDS ISN'T COUNTED AGAINST
THAT QUOTA. AND FINALLY DIRECTS
OSHA TO ENSURE THAT THESE NEW.
ALGORITHM DRIVEN WAREHOUSES
HAVE SAFETY STANDARDS SO WE CAN
STOP PEOPLE FROM GETTING HURT.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL FOR
THE FUTURE OF LOGISTICS AND
WAREHOUSES IN THIS COUNTRY AND
IN THE STATE. AND IT'S BEYOND
DOING WHAT HAS BECOME
UNFORTUNATELY A VERY DANGEROUS
JOB. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON A. B. SEVEN OH ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER DOLLARS MISTER
SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SMITH RECOGNIZED. OVER
AGAIN HERE. THANK THANK YOU TO
MY FELLOW COLLEAGUES AS A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER IN CALIFORNIA I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO SEVEN OH
ONE. THIS BILL WOULD DO NOTHING
BUT DRIVE UP THE COST FOR
BUSINESSES WHO ARE IN THE BEST
OF REBUILDING OUR ECONOMY AFTER
THE COVERT PANDEMIC. IN
ADDITION TO DRIVING UP COST OF
DOING BUSINESS. SICKNESS ALONG
TO THE CONSUMERS. THIS BILL
ALSO INCENTIVIZES FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUITS BASED ON VAGUE
STANDARDS AND THE EMPLOYER
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO PAY
ATTORNEY FEES EVEN IF THE
EMPLOYEE IS UNSUCCESSFUL. SMALL
BUSINESSES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
ARE OUT OF BREATH WITH THE
INCREASING GOVERNMENT
REGULATIONS. THESE BUSINESSES
ARE KNOCKED OUT TO GET
EMPLOYEES IN FACT A STUDY IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BY THE
WORK INSTITUTE ESTIMATE THE
COST OF EMPLOYEES TURN OVER
RICK EVALUATES. 35% OF THE
EMPLOYEES ANNUAL EARNINGS. I DO
IT DOES NOT MAKE SENSE FOR A
COMPANY TO IMPOSE PERFORMANCE
METRICS THAT LEAD TO HIGHER
RATES OF INJURIES OR
TERMINATIONS AS THIS BILL
SUGGEST. MANY OF US IN THIS
CHAMBER CAMPAIGN ONS SUPPORTING
SMALL BUSINESS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. SO LET'S SUPPORT
SMALL BUSINESSES HIRED THOUGH
NO VOTE ON AB SEVEN A ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER SMITH IS FOR
COOLEY IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. COLLEAGUES I DON'T
CONSIDER THIS TO BE A SMALL
BUSINESS BILL I'M PLEASED TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF IT. I THINK
THAT THERE IS A THREAD THAT
NEEDS TO RUN THROUGH THE
WORKPLACE OF RESPECT. FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL WORKER. I'M OLD
ENOUGH THAT I REMEMBER WHEN
THERE WAS A BIG SENSATION WHEN
I WOULD MY DAYS AT CAL B. F.
SKINNER THE BEHAVIORAL
PSYCHOLOGIST THE ONE WHO RAN
EXPERIMENTS OF VARIOUS TYPES OF
ANIMALS BEING GIVEN A STIMULUS
AND GETTING A RESPONSE AND- YOU
KNOW. LIFE IS NOT. TO BE LIVE
FEELING LIKE YOUR SQUIRREL
RUNNING IN A WHEEL. AND I SEE
THIS BILL AS AN EFFORT TO KIND
OF LOOK AT THE INDIVIDUAL
WORKER WHO IS DEPENDENT UPON A
PAYCHECK. AND TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS. A CONTACT
WHATEVER SETTING THEY FIND
THEMSELVES PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILY AND LOVED ONES. OF
RESPECT AND OF. KNOWLEDGE ABOUT
WHAT IS THE MEASURE
PERFORMANCE. AND I THINK IT IS
A GOOD BILL AND THEY- I'M
PLEASED TO SUPPORT- GINGIVAL.
THANK YOU MR COOLEY. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER METHODOLOGY LIKE
CLASS. I WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND
TO THE INACCURACIES OF THE
OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENTS BUT
THERE ARE SO MANY I'M NOT SURE
I CAN REMEMBER THEM ALL BUT
LET'S START WITH THIS NUMBER
ONE- THE RELIEF UNDER THIS BILL
IS CURATIVE THROUGH PADA SO IN
OTHER WORDS IT'S POPPED UP BUT
WITH THE RIGHT TO CURE FOR
THIRTY DAYS YOU KNOW SO GIVE
THE BUSINESS A RIGHT HERE.
SECONDLY THERE IS INJUNCTIVE
RELIEF THE PARTY HAS TO PREVAIL
IN ORDER FOR ATTORNEY FEES- TO
BE AWARDED IN INJUNCTIVE RELIEF
IN OTHER WORDS IF IT IF THAT
THE WORKERS IT'S JUST SUING TO
STOP THE BEHAVIOR THIS IS NOT-
A PERFECT PRIVATE RIGHT ACTION
IT'S NOT AUTOMATIC PAGA THIS IS
A AS A- AS GENTLE AS WE CAN DO
ENFORCEMENT IF YOU WILL- THIS
IS NOT SMALL BUSINESSES WERE
TALKING ABOUT OBVIOUSLY THIS IS
A LARGE WAREHOUSES. AND I YOU
KNOW IT'S A COMMON SENSE BILL I
CAN'T AGAIN BELIEVE WE ACTUALLY
HAVE TO DO A BILL TO SAVE LET
PEOPLE USE THE RESTROOM AND GET
A DRINK OF WATER THANK YOU I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. MEMBERS THIRTY VERY VOCAL.
BURKE WILL. WHO'S THE ROLE AND
TELEVOTE ICE FORTY EIGHT NO
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
SEVEN TEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS IF YOU'RE
GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES IN RECENT YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN ACTION TO
GUARANTEE THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY. OF CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
AN AGRICULTURAL FIELD WORKERS
BY ENSURING THE USE OF SAFE
CHEMICALS. AND THE RIGHT TO A
LIVING WAGE. EIGHTY SEVEN TEN
WOULD REQUIRE CERTAIN
AGRICULTURE PRODUCTS SOLD TO
THE PUBLIC TO BE PRODUCED IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR STATE'S
REGULATIONS. THIS BILL WOULD
PLACE OUR PESTICIDE REGULATIONS
ON A SHORT LIST OF STATE OUT OF
STATE PROGRAMS AND OUR LABOR
REGULATIONS. ON THESE SAME
PRODUCTS FOR OUT OF COUNTRY
PRODUCTS. FARMERS IN THE STATE
PRODUCE FRUITS VEGETABLES NUTS
MEATS AND OTHER TYPES OF.
COMMODITIES THAT MEET THE STATE
PESTICIDE LABOR AND WAGE.
REQUIREMENTS COMPLYING WITH THE
STATE LAWS- INCREASE THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS- THE ENVIRONMENT AND
THE WORKERS WHO PRODUCE THESE
CUTS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU MR GARCIA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THOSE VERY
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED VERY VOTE. WORK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLIED ABOUT
EYES FORTY SIX NEWS FIFTEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL
NOW MOVE THE FILE ITEM FOR AB
THREE THREE THREE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF RECONSIDERATION THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE THIRTY THREE BY FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER AND
ACTUALLY IN THE CRIMINAL GAINS.
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO GRANT
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO BRING THIS
ITEM UP FOR RECONSIDERATION.
SEEING AND HEARING AND THE
CLERK WILL READ THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE DEATH. ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE THIRTY THREE WITH THE
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER. DOCTOR ARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT THE
UNLIMITED AB THREE THREE THREE
MM IT'S WILL DO THE FOLLOWING
REMOVE THE LANGUAGE REQUIRING
THAT IN ORDER TO SHOW A QUOTE
PATTERN OF CRIMINAL GANG
ACTIVITY THE PROSECUTION PROVE
THAT THE OFFENSE IS COMMONLY
BENEFITED AT LEAST ONE
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIED MEMBER
OF THE GANG OTHER THAN THE
PERSON WHO COMMITTED THE
OFFENSES. REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE
PROSECUTION PROVE THE ALLEGED
GANG HAS AN ESTABLISHED
HIERARCHY. REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT PROSECUTION PROVE
THE DEFENDANT KNOWS THE PERSON
WHO COMMITTED THE OFFENSES USED
TO ESTABLISH THE PATTERN OF
CRIMINAL GANG ACTIVITY AND THE
REQUIREMENT THAT PEOPLE WHO
COMMITTED THE OFFENSES USED TO
ESTABLISH A PATTERN OF CHEMICAL
CRIMINAL GANG ACTIVITY WHERE
MEMBERS OF THE CRIMINAL STREET
GANG SUBSET AT THE TIME THOSE
OFFENSES WERE COMMITTED. I
REQUEST THAT THE AMENDMENTS TO
BE ADOPTED PUT OUT TO PRINT AND
PLACE BACK ON FILE THANK YOU
THANK YOU DR WEBER. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. ALTHOUGH SAY NO
THE AMENDMENT- YEAH I HAVE IT
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED. OUT
TO PRINT BACK ON FILE. THIS
PRESS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTION THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE SIXTY NINE EIGHT I'M SORRY
SIXTY NINE B. TO ALLOW AUTHORS
TO TAKE A FLOOR AMENDMENTS ON
THE FOLLOWING BILLS. ITEM TO
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN OH
SEVEN CORK AND ITEM TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN AB TWELVE TWENTY THREE
LEVINE. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM NINETY
FIVE AB NINE FIFTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SUMIKO NINE FIFTEEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT. IF YOU'RE
SURE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER EIGHTY NINE
FIFTEEN WILL HELP OUR STATE
LIVE UP TO ITS PROMISE TO
SUPPORT OUR SMALL AND DIVERSE
BUSINESSES. IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER SIGNED
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER ESTABLISHING
A GOAL FOR ALL STATE AGENCIES
THAT 25% OF CONTRACTS GO TO
SMALL BUSINESSES SINCE THEN
ONLY TWELVE OUT OF TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY ONE STATE AGENCIES
DEPARTMENTS. PURCHASING POWER
FOR STATE AND ENORMOUS HIT OUR
BUSINESSES PARTICULARLY OUR
SMALL MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
HAVE TAKEN DURING THIS PANDEMIC
WERE SQUANDERING A REAL
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THESE
BUSINESSES RECOVER. THIS BILL
WOULD CODIFY THAT 25% GOING TO
LAW CREATE A FAST TRACK
CERTIFICATION FOR DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS ENTERPRISES AND CREATE
AND ECONOMIC EQUITY FIRST
POLICY FOR PICKERING GOODS.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT AS
OUR BUSINESSES RECOVER. WE WILL
MAKE SURE THAT MORE STATE
CONTRACTS ARE PERFORMED BY
LOCAL SMALL AND DIVERSE
BUSINESSES I APPRECIATE THE
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL WITH ZERO NO VOTES
THUS FAR RESPECT THE ASTER I
VOTE. THANK YOU MR CHIU SEEING
HEARING FURTHER ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS. HOME VOTED A VERITABLE.
WE'RE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW I SIX JUNE THERE ARE
MEASURE HAS. WE WILL PASS
THIRTY BY ANYMORE FORTY WE'RE
BACK IN FILE ORDERED ILE A ONE
FOR FOUR. AB ELEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME MIDDLE THIRTEEN
BY SOME MEMBER WILL AND OTHERS
AND. TO THROUGH AND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MAY
SPEAKERMEMBERS MUCH OF THE MOD
RESEARCH MOVING CAN TRACE ROOTS
BACK TO HUMBLE COUNTY AND THE
CITY OF ARCADIA MY DISTRICT FOR
DECADES LEADERS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES HAVE LED THE WAY.
TRAGICALLY AS IT STANDS TODAY
IT IS EFFECTIVELY IMPOSSIBLE
FOR RESIDENTS OF HUMBOLDT
COUNTY TO REDEEM THEIR CRB
CONTAINERS WE WORK WITH LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY
HANDFUL SMALL CHANGES THAT
WOULD ALLOW RECYCLING CENTERS
TO RE OPEN IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY.
THESE MODEST CHANGES BY AND
WE'LL BY NO MEANS SOLVE ALL THE
PROBLEMS FACING THE BOTTLE BILL
PROGRAM THESE DAYS THE ADDRESS
A CRISIS IN MY DISTRICT AND
HOPEFULLY THEY WILL HELP OTHER
COMMUNITIES STRUGGLING WITH
ACCESS TO REDEMPTION CENTERS
TO. THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AIBO.
THANK DOCTOR WOULDN'T IN HER NO
FURTHER DEBATE I'M MATTER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE- MEMBERS.
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
THROUGH THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED FOR OF. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE CALENDAR I
SAID KNOWS THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO ITEM ONE FOR FIVE. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME PEOPLE FOR TO
THREE BIAS MEMBER AND- OTHERS
AND ACT RELATING TO IN FROM. TO
MISTER CHAIR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE WOULD
ESTABLISH A ROADMAP FOR
REFORMING OUR STATE I. T.
SYSTEMS. WHILE OUR STATE LEADS
THE COUNTRY WHEN IT COMES TO
TECHNOLOGY OUR GOVERNMENT IT
SYSTEMS HAVE STRUGGLE TO
FUNCTION WE ALL KNOW THE
GREATEST HITS. DMV THIS CALL
REASON OF COURSE EDT. THERE'S
NO SILVER BULLET FOR ADDRESSING
THESE I. T. PROBLEMS IT'S BEEN
A COMBINATION OF A LACK OF
STANDARDIZED POLICIES IN A FINE
LEADERSHIP. THIS BILL WOULD LAY
THE GROUNDWORK FOR BROADER I.
T. REFORM. IT'S ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
ZERO NO VOTES AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE TO MODERNIZE
OUR IT SYSTEMS. THANK YOU MR
CHIU THING IN HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK OPEN THE- MEMBERS
VOTED VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THEIR TO VOTE. AND THEN WHICH
ONE- ALL MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF A.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW IT ICE FIVE NO ZERO MEASURE.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO I'D TO
SEVENTY. AB TWELVE THREE FOR
PER OF A- THE CLERK WILL READ.
SHE. SOME BILL TWELVE TWENTY
THREE WITH A MINUTE BY SO OF.
LIVING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
PURPOSES OF A- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR SPEAKER IN MEMBERS
THESE. TO A TWELVE TWENTY THREE
ESTABLISH THE GUN. FOR HE AND
RICK FUN TO GUN VIOLENCE
PROGRAMS GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION EDUCATION AND GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION RESEARCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE
AMENDMENTS BE ADOPTED AND THAT
THE BILL GO OUT TO PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE. THANK YOU.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY ICE.
OPPOSED SAY NO. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED ADAM
HOW TO IT BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS
WE WILL BE TAKING UP FILE ITEM
TO TWENTY EIGHT AB SEVEN OH
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN OH SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS BIASA QUIRK. DR
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M VERY PROUD
TO SAY THAT- MY STAFF HAS
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH BOTH
THE MANUACTURERS IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS. CONCERNED
ABOUT THE MERCURY THERMOSTAT
RETURN PROGRAM WE TRY TO GET
THOSE THERMOSTATS BACK. SO THAT
THE MERCURY CAN BE DISPOSED OF
PROPERLY- THIS MUCH DISTANCE
DISSATISFACTION WITH THE
PROGRAM. STAFF WORKING TOGETHER
WITH THE INDUSTRY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS HAVE COME
UP WITH A NEW SOLUTION TO THIS
THAT'S WHAT THESE AMENDMENTS
ARE ABOUT- THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU DR WORK THING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. THESE ARE FOR OF
AMENDMENTS ARE NOT OPEN THE
ROLE WITHOUT OBJECTION THINK OF
BETTER THE CEMENT- SAY AYE.
I'LL POST NO MANAGER DOCKED OUT
TO PER AND BACK ON.
FIVE
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE UP
IN FILE ORDER TO TAKE THE
SPEAKER PRO TEM BILLS UP TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX. AB NINE
FIVE NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FIFTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN THE PARK
DISTRICT'S. MISTER ALLEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU.
FANTASY MEMBERS PRESENTING A V.
NINE FIFTY NINE. EIGHTY NINE
FIFTY NINE WOULD ALLOW
INDEPENDENT PARK DISTRICTS TO
BE ABLE TO EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS A MULTITUDE
OF PUBLIC NUISANCES THAT THEY
CONFRONT REGULARLY EXAMPLES OF
NOOSES NUISANCES ON PARK
DISTRICT PLANS INCLUDE A LEGAL
WATER DIVERSION EXTENSION OF
YARDS IN THE PARK HABITAT
ILLEGAL DUMPING AND GRADING ON
AUTHORIZED LANDSCAPINGA LEGAL
STREAMBED ALTERATION ALL OF
WHICH MAY IMPACT SENSITIVE
HABITAT WILDFIRE PROTECTION
ZONES AND OTHER PARK SPECIFIC
USES. PARK DISTRICTS NEED TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS ILLEGAL
ENCROACHMENTS IN THE SAME
COMPREHENSIVE WAY THAT CITIES
COUNTIES AND OTHER SPECIAL
DISTRICTS CAN GIVE IN THAT PART
DISTRICTS ARE BEST SUITED TO
ADDRESS LAND STEWARDSHIP AND
MANAGEMENT ISSUES ON ITS OWN
LAND PROVIDING PARK DISTRICTS
WITH THE APPROPRIATE NUISANCE
ABATEMENT TOOLS WOULD BE THE
MOST EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE
ALLOCATION OF PUBLIC RESOURCES
MEASURE AS AN OPPOSITION. AND
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
SAYING HEARING FURTHER ON THE
MATTER CLERK WILL OPEN THE-
MEMBERS VOTE. TO VOTE. LONG
MEMBERS TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS AYE A- CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TELLING I SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS THE MEASURE PASSES.
IN A FILE ITEM NINETY ONE AB
EIGHT THIRTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN
ACCOLADES FOR DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES. IF YOUR MIND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU GET
MATTER SPEAK AND MEMBERS AB
EIGHT THIRTEEN MUSTAPHA OF
ADMINISTRATIVE PILOT PROGRAM TO
BETTER TRACK AND MEASURE
OUTCOMES AND QUALITY IN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
SERVICE AREA. THESE OUTCOMES
WILL INCLUDE CLEAR AND
CONSISTENT STANDARDS FOR
SERVICE DELIVERY AND MEASURE
THE SUCCESS THE CONSUMERS
EXPERIENCE AS THEY USE THE
SERVICES TO ACCESS THEIR CHOSEN
WAYS OF LIFE LAST YEAR ANALYSIS
OF THE DDS BUDGET FROM THE L.
A. L. LIKE KNOWLEDGE IS THAT
THE CURRENT DATA AVAILABLE
ABOUT DDS CONSUMERS AND
SERVICES ARE NOT COMPREHENSIVE.
AND ARE NOT COLLECTED IN A
SYSTEMATIC MANNER WHICH MAKES
UNDERSTANDING THE EXTENT TO
WHICH SERVICE NEEDS GO UNMET
ACROSS THE STATE VERY DIFFICULT
THE ANALYSIS FOR THE STATE TO
DDS DOES NOT COLLECT ENOUGH
DATA TO QUANTIFY WHETHER
SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE
SUFFICIENT CAPACITY TO MEET
CONSUMERS DIVERSE NEEDS OR
WHETHER CONSUMERS HAVE
SUFFICIENT CHOICE AMONG
PROVIDERS. THIS BILL SEEKS TO
FILL THIS GAP BY PARTNERING
WITH REGIONAL CENTERS AND
PROVIDERS TO DEVELOP DATA AND
QUALITY METRICS TO BETTER
EVALUATE HOW SERVICES ARE
DELIVERED AND REIMBURSE TO THE
TO THE IDT COMMUNITY. THROUGH
THE PASSAGE OF THIS LEGISLATION
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PILOT I
BELIEVE OUR STATE WILL BE
TAKING AN IMPORTANT STEP FOR
PROVIDING QUALITY SERVICES IN A
MANNER THAT WILL ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES DISABILITIES TO
PURSUE THEIR CHOSEN WAYS OF
LIFE IN THE COMMUNITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE. TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO A. YEAH. THE
ROLE AND HOW YOU THAT I SEVEN
FOUR NO ONE MEASURE PASSED.
MOVING BACK INTO ORDER WE WILL
PASS RETAINER FILE ONE FORTY
SIX MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY SEVEN AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE
AREA AND AN ACCOLADES A BILL
BUILDING SANDERS. IT'S BEEN A
VERY AND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES. THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING STANDARDS LOS THAT
WISHES THAT THE PURPOSE OF
CALIFORNIA'S BUILDING CODE IS
TO PRESERVE AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY. WELL
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT BUILDING
CODES ARE GOOD AT KEEPING
PEOPLE SAFE AND EARTHQUAKES ARE
CODES DO LITTLE TO PREVENT
DAMAGE LIMIT BUILDING CLOSER
TIMES OR LIMIT FINANCIAL LOSSES
FOR MOST BUILDINGS. AB THREE
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE HELPS
COMMUNITIES RECOVER MORE
QUICKLY FROM DAMAGING
EARTHQUAKES IN THREE WAYS. A
CLARIFIES THAT ARE BUILDING
CODE IS MEANT TO SUPPORT
RECOVERY AS WELL AS SAFETY TO
PROTECT LIVELIHOODS AS WELL AS
LIGHTS. BE IT ALLOWS CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO BUILD ON THE STATE
CODE TO ADDRESS RECOVERY AS A
LOCAL PRIORITY AND C. A.
CHARGES THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION TO SET
MINIMUM STATEWIDE REQUIREMENTS
RELATED TO POST EARTHQUAKE
RECOVERY. THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE
IS CONSISTENT WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS IN A RECENT
REPORT BY FEMA AND THIS THAT
AND WILL GIVE US BUILDING CODES
THAT REFLECT OUR SHARED
PRIORITIES. AND NEEDS IN TERMS
OF BOTH SAFETY AND RECOVERY
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS.
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
FLORIDA A. BURKE WILL HELLO THE
ROLE AND HOW IT ALL FIFTY KNOWS
NINETEEN MEASURE PASS. FOR THE
PAST THIRTY BY LAW ONE EIGHT
THROUGH ONE FIFTY ONE MOVIE THE
FILE I ONE FIFTY TWO AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY THE CLERK WILL
READ. WE WILL THIRTEEN SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLY CALDERON AND- IN OUR-
TO PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES. CALL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM AND MEMBER ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT SIX TWO
STABILISED THE ENHANCED
SERVICES PROGRAM FOR SALIH OR
E. S. P. A. FOR SHORT. WITHIN
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES THE S. P. A. WILL
PROVIDE A SIGNED LEASE WITH
CULTURALLY COMPETENT CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES FOR UP TO
NINETY DAYS AND WITH IT ACCESS
TO ALL THE BENEFITS AND WHICH
THEIR LAWFULLY ENTITLED TO.
WITH THE CREATION OF THE S. P.
A. AB THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL
MIRROR WHAT IS CURRENTLY
OFFERED FOR REFUGEES. THIS BILL
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF
COMMITTEE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU MISTER CALDERON SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. VOTE VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IT. WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN HOW THE I. SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES- IN A FIVE ITEM ONE
FIFTY THREE THREE EIGHT FOR THE
CLERK OVER. ASSEMBLY THIRTEEN
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE THE
FINAL. THREE ZERO ARE. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TODAY 2% AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR WITH ONE POWER THE
STATE TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK SO THAT
AGENCIES CAN WORK
COLLABORATIVELY TO ADDRESS OUR
CLIMATE CRISIS. JACKSON CLIMATE
CHANGE OF FELT THROUGHOUT CAN.
LAST YEAR. IN WOODLAND HILLS IN
MY DISTRICT REACHED A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY ONE DEGREES. THE
HIGHEST READING EVER RECORDED
IN L. A. COUNTY. WELL THE
LEGISLATORS ENACTED FRAMEWORKS
AND ENDORSE VARIOUS POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS CALIFORNIA
STILL LACKS GOVERNANCE
PRIORITIZATION AND METRICS ON
CRITICAL ACTIONS AND TIMELINES
TO ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE
ADAPTATION GOALS. AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR ADDRESSES THIS GAP
BY TASKING THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCIL WITH DEVELOPING AND
COORDINATING A STRATEGIC RESULT
IN C. PRIMARK. THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
ENVIRONMENT ORGANIZATIONS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MAY GABRIEL C.
IN HERE NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
MATTER BECAUSE WILL- OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO VERY VOTE.
CLERK WILL LOWS THE ROLE AND
HOW IT APPLIES FIFTY FOREIGNERS
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
WILL PASS AND RETAIN PILOT ONE
THROUGH FOUR AND ONE FIFTY.
BILLION FILE ITEM ONE FIFTIES
BABY FORTY SEVENTY THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY
SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY FREE AND-
IN A- COMMUNITY CALL. FRAZIER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MATHIS CALIFORNIA'S SO SUPPORT
THAN THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND INTO. AND COMMUNITIES.
MANY OF WHOM HAVE WOULD HAVE
HISTORY BEEN SERVED STATE RUN
IS SAY. PER THE LETTERMAN ACT
THIS OF HAS A LEGAL ON. TO
SUPPORT PEOPLE WITH THE
DISABILITIES TO LIVE IN
COMMUNITY SETTINGS AND TO
PURSUE INDIVIDUAL GOALS. MANY
REAL QUICK REAL PUT A RELY ON
DIRECT SERVICE STAFF FOR CARE.
SUPERVISION TRAINING AND
SUPPORT TO MAKE COMMUNITY
LIVING POSSIBLE. TODAY'S
TURNOVER OFDIRECT SERVICE
STAFF IS WAY TOO HIGH DUE TO
THE FLOW. OF LOW WAGES THAT
THEY'RE PAID FOR THIS CRITICAL
WORK. PROFESSIONALIZATION OF
THIS WORKFORCE THROUGH
OPPORTUNITIES OF ENHANCED
TRAINING AND CERTIFICATION WILL
NOT ONLY ENHANCE PROVIDER
RETENTION BUT ALSO CREATE A
PATHWAY FOR UPWARD CAREER
MOVEMENT. AB FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN
WILL GIVE THEM THAT OPPORTUNITY
BY REQUIRING THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
TO DEVELOP A MODEL CURRICULUM
FOR CERTIFICATION PROCESS AND
PROGRAM FOR PROVIDERS OF CARE
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
WHICH WILL BE OFFERED AT
COMMITTEE COLLEGE CAMPUSES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER
ST MR MEDINA ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I RISE
IN IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
SEVEN TEEN- IT IS SO IMPORTANT
THAT WORKERS WHO WORK WITH
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED OF
FOLKS HAVE THE TRAINING THAT'S
NECESSARY AND HAVE A PATH TO-
PROFESSIONAL CERTIFICATE A AS
CHAIR OF HIGHER ED I'M VERY
PROUD TO SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AND- DR VOTE THANK YOU MR
MEDINA SAYING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISTER FRAZIER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. WELL THE ROLE.
MEMBERS A VERITABLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED THE. ALL MEMBERS
ROAD VERY LOW. BURKE WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT I
SEVENTY KNOWS THAT MEASURE. WE
WILL NOTIFY ITEM ONE SEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY ONE WILL
READ. LISTEN GO FOURTEEN THE
ONE US MEMBER AND I BELIEVE IN
THE FORCE. FRAZIER ARE AT.
THANK YOU MATT SPEAKER. AND
MEMBER IN THE PAST SEVERAL
WHILE HAVING IN A- AND
DESTRUCTIVE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF. INCREASE FROM ONE
AVERAGE OF ABOUT SIXTY ACRE AND
YOU. BETWEEN NINE. FIFTY OR
NINETEEN. NINETIES TO MORE THAN
ONE MILLION ACRES ANNUALLY.
THIS DECADE ALONE. THE
CONDITION OF CALIFORNIA'S FORCE
HAVE LED TO HIGHER INTENSITY
WILDFIRES THERE ARE FAR MORE
DESTRUCTIVE THAN WHEN THE
FOURSOME WELLENS WERE IN A MORE
ECOLOGICAL BENEFICIAL RESILIENT
CONDITION. WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE ALSO BECOME ONE
OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT SOURCES
OF GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
FROM AIR POLLUTION. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A BROAD REPRESENTATIVE
OF LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
AGENCIES FINALIZE THE
CALIFORNIA FOREST CARBON PLAN
TO SET GOALS TO IMPROVE FOREST
HEALTH. PREVENT AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
HIGH SEVERITY WILDFIRES AND
PROMOTE CARBON SEQUESTRATION IN
FORESTS AND WILDLANDS. THE PLAN
IS THE RESULT OF SEVERAL YEARS
OF CAREFUL COLLABORATION
INCLUDES VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
THAT FUELS TREATMENT STRATEGIES
THE FORCE CARBON PLANS GOALS
ALSO SERVE AS THE FOUNDATION
FOR GOVERNOR NEWS OF MORE
RECENT FORCE MANAGEMENT TASK
FORCE ACTION PLAN. WELL OFTEN
CITED AS A ROAD MAP FOR CUT
REDUCING EMISSIONS FROM
CALIFORNIA'S DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES THE CALIFORNIA'S.
FOREST CARBON PLAN GOALS HAVE
NO STATUTORY AUTHORITY BEHIND
THEM TO. DEMONSTRATE THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING
FOREST HEALTH REDUCING WILDFIRE
RISK AND INCREASING CARBON
SEQUESTRATION. A. B. AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE DOES THE
FOLLOWING. CODIFIES THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY GOALS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOR ITS CURRENT PLAN
STRESSES THE URGENCY OF
IMPROVING FOREST HEALTH AND
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM WILDFIRES. IT
REQUIRES THE STATE TO IDENTIFY
THOSE RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS AND FINALLY
PROVIDES THE LEGISLATURE
GREATER OVERSIGHT A RECORD WITH
REQUIRING CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY THANK YOU
HELLO EPA. TO REPORT ANNUALLY
ON THE PROGRESS MEETING THESE
GOALS I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. VERITABLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
VERY VOTE. THAT. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE ANTI THAT I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO MEASURE
PASS. WILL NEED TO FILE ITEM
SIXTY FORTY FIFTY FIVE A
CURRENT. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
FEET FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
IN CLAIMS OF PUBLIC. WITH WORKS
YOU ARE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. AB FORTY FIFTY
FIVE WOULD GIVE VICTIMS OF SEX
ASSAULT BY LAW FOR OFFICE TEN
YEARS OUT THE DATE OF. AND A
CRIMINAL CASE TEN YEARS. AFTER
THE LONG FOR ALL NO LONGER BY
THE AGENCY WE IS LATER TO FILE
A CIVIL CLAIM THE DAMAGE FOR
THE ASSAULT. THIS BILL
KNOWLEDGES AND DIRECTLY THE
INTIMIDATE BARRIERS TO RIP.
VICTIMS WHEN THEY KNOW THERE
ARE CAN PUNISH A OR TELL YOU TO
GET THEM FROM OF. THIS HAS NO
OPPOSITION AS MY PER SUPPORT
AND THE SUPPORT OF A HEALTH
WOMEN'S LOS AND OTHER THAT
WOULD RISK ASK FOR AND I. THANK
YOU MAY WAXING OF DEBATE THE
MATTER WILL THE ROLE. REMEMBER
BOTH VERY A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
VERY VOTE. BURKE WELL THE ROLL
INTO YOU THAT I SIXTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE AND TO. A PATH OR A
FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTY NINE ONE
SIX TWO ONE MOVING FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY TO EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SIXTY ONE A QUICK OVER. ASSUME
FOURTEENTH ONE BY SOME RADIUS
ACCOLADE HUMAN SO. THREE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY PRESENT
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE WHICH
ENSURES OUR VICTIMS HAVE ACCESS
TO THE CRITICAL SERVICES. AND
RESOURCES. AS WE TURNED
TRANSITION OUT OF COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. OTHER
VEHICLE WITH NINETEEN PANDEMIC
WE MUST ENSURE IMMIGRANT
VICTIMS OF CRIME RECEIVE
SERVICES IN A TIMELY MANNER. SB
FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE CLOSES A
LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT LAW SO WE
CAN ALLOW QUALIFIED VICTIMS OF
CRIME TO RECEIVE SERVICESTHIS
BILL PASSED OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE WITH
FULL BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MAY S. HEARING
NO FOR DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE
WILL THE ROLE. VERY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED A VERITABLE. HOME
THOSE WHO SERVE. CLERK WILL.
WHO'S THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I FIFTY NINE AS ONE THAT
MIGHT PASSES MOVING TO AND. THE
SESSION SCHEDULED AS FOLLOWS
MONDAY MAY THIRTY FIRST IS A
HOLIDAY FOR MEMORIAL DAY
TUESDAY JUNE FIRST IS FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM. THERE'S A
YEAH. THIS IS GONNA. MEMBERS.
AS YOU KNOW THIS IS THE MORE
DAY WEEK BEFORE FOR WE RETURN
HOME. DID TIME WITH OUR LOVED
ONES REFLECT THOSE TO WHO AVE
THE FULL MEASURE OF THE TO
NATION WE WILL FIRST RECOGNIZE
MISTER VOTE FOR SPECIAL AND.
SHORT WORDS FROM DAY. THERE ARE
THREE DAYS. IN THE YEAR THAT WE
HONOR. I VETERANS AND- ARMED
FORCES DAY FOR THOSE THAT KERN
WHERE THE U. VETR DAY FOR THOSE
USE TO WEAR THE UNIFORM.
MEMORIAL DAY FOR THOSE WHO
NEVER MADE IT OUT OF THE YOU
KNOW FOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR VOEPEL FOR THIS MEANINGFUL
WORDS. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN TO ALMOST TEN SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
MISS RASMUSSEN MISS WALDRON
SECONDS AT THIS HOUSE STANDARD
TURNED INTO TUESDAY JUNE FIRST
TWO ONE PM QUORUM CALLS LIFTED.
THE CHANGE TOO. FILE AND ONE
SIXTY TWO AB FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE
CHANGING FROM NO TO AYE. BURKE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
ASSEMBLE FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE NO
TÁI.
TÁI., WELL CHANGE IN MY MEMBER
CORK SILVA ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ASSEMBLY BILL AB SEVEN ZERO ONE
HI TEN ON VOTE. COULD CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN A ONE- TO
NOT VOTING.
BOERNER HORVATH
VOTE CHANGE AB TEN FORTY ONE
NOTES ARE NOT VOTING. BURKE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN FORTY ONE NO TO NOT VOTING.